[موسيقى]
استدعى حاكم البلاد مستشاره وكلفه بصياغه
قرار يرفع سعر السكر بنسبه 10% ويدعو فيه
الشعب الى الصبر والتحمل فبث المستشار
اشاعات في الاسواق بان الحاكم ينوي زياده
50% على سعر السكر والزيت واللحم والتمر
والقمح والشعير فضج الناس ساخطين غاضبين
وفي الاسبوع التالي بث المستشار اشاعه
ثانيه تؤكد قرب اصدار الحاكم قراره بتحريض
من بعض المستشارين اخذ الناس يتجادلون ظلم
كبير هذه السله الضرائبي فلو كانت 10 او
حتى 15% وعلى ماده واحده لهان الامر في
هذه اللحظه بالذات ذهب المستشار الى
الحاكم وكتب نص القرار تلبيه لرغبات شعبنا
العظيم قررنا عدم الانصات لمستشاري السوء
واكتفينا بزياده
12% على سعر السكري فقط فتنفس الناس
الصعداء وهتفوا عاش الحاكم عاش الزعيم
الذي منح المستشار رخصه استيراد السكر الى
العناوين ايفانكا ميلينيا وتيريزا رقصنا
لاسباب
مختلفه بورصه الكويت تخسر ملياري دولار
صبيحه زياره
السيسي وزير تونسي عاشق لايطاليا الجزائر
شيوعيه وليبيا
مخيفه شيخ مصري يدعي ان الرسول كان مسيحيا
قبل
الاسلام صولاغ العراقي متعدد المهن
والمواهب ينافس المنجمين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في فرنسا يدخل قصر الاليزيه مع
امانويل ماكرون زوجته والجمهوريه الواحده
والعائله الاوروبيه بحسب ماكرون لكن
الرابح الاكبر يبقى ضمنيا والد المرشح
الخاسره جان ماري لوبان الذي تعرض لخيانات
متكرره من ابنته مارين المغضوب بالتوصيف
العربي عربيا ابرز الخاسرين سقوط مارين
بشار الاسد الذي لم تخفي لوبان توجهاتها
بدعمه اما وزير خارجيته فلم يهتم بنتيجه
الانتخابات الفرنسيه ولماذا يهتم
بانتخابات جرت في دوله ضمن قاره اخفاها عن
الخريطه منذ ست سنوات ديفيد كوبرفيلد
العرب وليد المعلم نحن لا نعول على الدور
الاوروبي فكيف نعول على الدور الفرنسي
تذكرون منذ
2011 انا شطبت اوروبا من
الخارطه وحتى الان لم تظهر مجددا يوم
الانتخاب مضى واليوم يوم اخر رقص لوبان
ولعب لماكرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليست مارين وحدها من رقص هذا الاسبوع
ايفانكا ترامب ايضا نشرت فيديو لرقصها
امام طفليها بعد عناء يوم
طويل ميلينيا ترامب الزوجه كادت ترقص من
الفرح لتغريده تويتر ساخره من العجز
السياسي لبعلها تقول يبدو ان الجدار
الوحيد الذي شيده دونالد هو الذي يفصل
بينه وبين ميلينيا فسجلت المدام اع جابها
بالسخريه ثم سحبته رئيسه وزراء بريطانيا
تيريزا ماي رقصت من البرد في مدينه ابردين
شاير باسكتلندا حيث اقفل المواطنون
ابوابهم في وجهها عندما حاولت تسليمهم
نشرات انتخابيه
صدرج نزلت دموع
الباب عمرك شفت ش باب عم
يبكي
في اخبارنا الاقتصاديه 2 مليار دولار 2.2
مليار دولار خسرتها بورصه الكويت هذا
الاسبوع في جلسه تداول واحده هذه السابقه
في هذا العام حصلت صبيحه وصول الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي الى الكويت حيث اجرى
محادثات وصفت
بالمثمن بيتعوض والمهم الصحه كمل مشوارك
للسكه لسه في
اولها قل بس يا يا رب وربنا على خيرها
كمل كمل مشوارك السكه لسه في
اولها قل بس يا رب وربنا على خيرها
يكمل علي عبد الله صالح كان قذافي ستايل
هذا الاسبوع فدعا انصاره الى ان يفكروا
بعقولهم والى ان يقفوا على
ارجلهم اوقفوا على
اقدامكم وفكروا برؤوسكم وثقافات سواء كنت
علماء او محدودين
العلم والعيب الذي لا يتعلم ولا يعب ولا
يتابع ولا يفهم البكا خل
البكالي كم شجا قلبك من محبب
غالي ما
شجاني ما
شجاني البسطاء هم غالبا من يدفعون اثمان
الحروب اما القاده فعندما يلتقون يضحكون
فيديو مسرب من لقاء جمع رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي الليبي فايز السراج واللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر طغط عليه الالفه
والموده التي يتمنى الليبيون انعكاسها
وتعميمها على القواعد الشعبيه مندوبو
احزاب جزائريه نائمون في اقلام الاقتراع
ولا يعرفون اسماء رؤساء
احزابهم اسمه رئيس الحزب ر الحب والله مال
بالي
تمت الحس
بالكوادر الوادر اسمه شعره شايف
اسمه صباح
الخير علك تعيط كيف
[موسيقى]
ج ا مايهمنيش ش يهمني انا فيهم يهموني
دراهم انا يا دنيا شتي مصاري شت علينا فلو
في ساعه تخل عن الفطنه والمسؤوليه
واللياقه قال وزير الشؤون المحليه والبيئه
التونسي رياض المؤخر في روما عندما يسالني
الناس اين تقع تونس افضل ان اقول تحت
ايطاليا فليس من اللائق ان تقع تونس بين
الجزائر الشيوعيه وليبيا المخيفه بحسب
سخريته وقع خلط بين تونس واندونيسيا
فسالوني اين تقع تونس فقلت انها جانب
ليبيا وفي تلك الفتره كانت تبدو الى حد ما
بلدا ارهابيا وكانت الجزائر شيوعيه ولذلك
عندما يسالونني اين تقع تونس فكنت اجيب هي
تحت ايطاليا اه يا لائق مؤكد انك تفهم
بالطقس حتى صرت وزيرا مختار التليلي مدرب
كره قدم تونسي يستشهد بايه قرانيه كريمه
على انها قول ماثور لبر قيبه والخوف من من
ان يسمع ليل الاذان فيعتقد انه موال لصباح
فخري انا نزع المقوله اللي قالها ابجيب لا
يغير الل بقوم حتى يغير بانفسهم اذا الشعب
التونسي مش قال بجيبا بجيبه استشهد بها
بجيبه استشهد بها بجيبه ايه سشد بها بجيبه
بارك الله فيك
عادل نتنياهو الذي اتهم حماس بتربيه
الاطفال على القتل كان يضيف حصه الى
المنهاج الدرا الاسرائيلي كيف تقتل
فلسطينيا فمثلت الشرطه امام تلامذه
المستوطنين الصغار عمليه اعدام فلسطيني في
الشارع والى الرئيس محمود عباس وجه سهامه
واتهامه بتمويل من وصفهم
بالارهابيين كيف تستطيع الحديث عن السلام
مع الاسرائيليين وانت توفر الدعم المالي
لاناس قتلوا اسرائيليين ابرياء الغي
الرواتب التي تدفع للقتل والقانون الذي
يجيز دفعها مول السلام وليس القتل وفيما
كان شمعه الانسانيه نتنياهو يذوب محاضرا
في السلام كان خمسه من جنوده المدججين
يعدمون بالرصاص الحارق والدم البارد
الطفله الفلسطينيه فاطمه حجيجي على قارعه
الطريق بحجه انها كانت تنوي تنفيذ عمليه
الطعن وقد وضع الجنود سكينا على جثتها
للتمويه كما المحت الى ذلك الخارجيه
الفلسط يه فاطمه حجيجي بيل سانه كسرت من
البستان الذي لونته بحضورها اللطيف في
وسائل التواصل كيفكم ان شاء الله مبسوطين
شاركونا على سناب تو انا فاطمه وانا
[موسيقى]
براءه سيطير الفساد من لبنان بالانترنت
البطيء رئيس الحكومه سعد الحريري يكشف كيف
سيتم القضاء على الفساد من خلال الحكومه
الالكترونيه التي تزم انشائها لتحديث عمل
الادارات العامه في البلاد ولكن لسه
المواطن بس يروح على على وزاره وعلى اي
مؤسسه بده يحمل الورقه ولازم يطبع عليها
ويرجع يروح على محل ثاني وياخذ كمان ورقه
ثانيه من اداره ثانيه والاداره ثالثه وهون
يكمن الشيطان شيخ سعد الفساد في لبنان له
عده مقاسات الاكس اكس لارج هو مقاس الكبار
والكبير بده كبير وهؤلاء لا يقفون في
الطوابير لبنان بلد الوص اكيد بالواسطه كل
شي بيمشي عندك هون بالبلد اجباري بدك تدفع
رش ولا تخلص معاملات ما دفع رش بلبنان كله
كله بدفع الله يخلينا الوزراء
والنواب يا حبيبي وهذا رئيس الجامعه
اللبنانيه فؤاد ايوب يقول قبل ايام امام
رئيس الجمهوريه ان الجامعه تعاني من
تجاذبات ومن محاصصات طائفيه وتعاني من
التدخلات السياسيه في شؤونها الداخليه
سعيا الى محاصصات طائفيه حزبيه وسياسيه
وكانها مؤسسه لتمرير الخدمات على حساب
مصالحها وقوانينها مفتي النظام السوري
احمد حسون ركب سيناريو مشهد من خياله نسبه
الى يوم القيامه ومثله على الهواء في يوم
الشهداء نحيي شهدائهم ايضا الذين اختلطت
دمائهم بدمائنا وفي السماء تقف امام الله
فيقول للشاب الايراني وللشاب اللبناني
وللشاب الروسي لماذا استشهدت في ارض سوريا
يقولون لانك مع سوريا الله معك سوريا
سوريا الله
[موسيقى]
معها في مصر التنوع قائم فهذا عمر اديب
يتساءل
متى سينتقدون الرئاسه اداء السيسي
واخفاقات ما تتكلم قول مش عاجبني مش
عاجبني اللي
بيجرى هترشح نفسك ازاي قولوا مش عاجبنا مش
نافع نافع ولو عاجبكم خلاص يبقى بترشح
نفسك ليه لعزم مجاهد راي اخر فهو سرح في
خطوات السيسي فاحس بالراحه
ان يصدقوه سرحت في خطوات الرئيس
السيسي كل كلامه وعمله واشتغل في نفس
الظروف اللي عاشها محمد
علي وبعدين وبصراحه حسيت براحه غريبه جدا
وتفاؤل
وتاكدت ان احنا مع رئيس
بيبني صدقوني
بيبني ل 200 سنه قدام مصطفى بكري كان من
الشجاعه ان طالب السيسي بعدم وضع اي زياده
اخرى على الاسعار يعني اوكي الزيادات دي
ماشيه الحال لكن ما تفكرش بغيرها الان
الحاجه الاساسيه واللي انا بتوجه بيه
لسياده
الرئيس غلاء الاسعار يا فندم بقى زياده عن
الحد والشعب المصري مستحمل بالكاد
اتخنق ولا يجب ان تكون هناك زياده اخرى
لميس الحديدي وفي تعليقه على الاعتداءات
التي تتعرض لها القوات المصريه تطلب من
وزاره الداخليه ايضاحات عن كيفيه اختراق
معلومات الاجهزه الامنيه حول مواعيد وامكن
القطعات العسكريه المتحركه وعايزين نسال
وانا عارفه ان كلامي ده ممكن يعرضني
للمسائله بس لازم دوري ان انا اسال ازاي
قول امني متحرك يتم استهدافه بهذا الشكل
ريهام سعيد لم تشغل راسها مثل لميس
بالمشاغب وبمساحه الحكومه الجزمه دي لازم
تتحط فوق راسنا من فوق انا بقى ممكن احطها
كده عشان الواحد يفهم القيمه الحقيقيه و
وهحطها فوق راسي تاني وتالت وهاتها لنا
وان حطها فوق راسي عند في
باسم وعند في اي حد هيعترض
ريهام لم تتفوق على احمد موسى الذي كان
ادائه عاليا على ارض المعركه في جبل
الحلال حياتي كلها كوم واليوم ده بالنسبه
لي كوم
تاني لان ما كنتش متخيل
ابدا
انه القوات المسلحه بتعمل كده عارف
بيعملوا ايه بس مش كده ما كنتش
متخيل انهم
بيواجهوا
ده
ابدا ما كتش
[موسيقى]
متخي ان احنا كلنا مع احترام
الجمي امام الرجاله دي ما نساش حاجه وزير
الثقافه المصريه الاسبق جابر عصفور سخف
الحضاره الاسلاميه والصق بها تهمه العنف
والارهاب تنوع على فكره الحضاره الاسلاميه
لم تكن حضاره ذهبيه كما نتخيل احيانا
والحضاره الاسلاميه كانت تنتج العنف قرنا
بعد قرن ايضا لحفظ التنوع في مصر اقيل
رئيس جامعه الازهر بسبب وصفه شخصا يسب
الصحابه والامام البخاري بحسب سعيد حساسي
بالمرتد الحقيقه انا مش مبسوط من جوايا مش
مبسوط من جوايا ان انا اقيل رئيس جامعه
الازهر لمجرد انه قال كلمه على واحد ورجع
تاني اعتذر عشان خاطر اسلام البحير اللي
بيسب في الصحابه وبيسبب خاري ويسب مش عارف
يسب ابونا
راخر ايه الجلال ده بتاع الراجل ده ايه
الهيبه دي بتاع اسلام البحيري ده قمه
التنوع اي يدعي شيخ مصري ينتحل صفه مفتي
استاذ
ان الرسول محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام كان
مسيحيا قبل الاسلام الاعلامي محمد علي خير
مصعوق النهارده انا قريت حوار لواحد مسمي
نفسه مفتي استراليا مصطفى راشد بيقول لك
ان سيدنا
النبي الرسول عليه افضل الصلاه والسلام
كان مسيحيا قبل
الاسلام وان اللي نصره ورقه بن نوفل
وان هو كان نصراني هو والسيده خديجه زوجته
الاولى وقال لك ان الحج الشرعي ده مفتي
استراليا مفتي يعني انت هتروح تاخد منه
فتوى والحج الشرعي الحج الشرعي ينبغي ان
يكون الى جبل الطور في سيناء وليس الى
الكعبه كل هذا التنوع في مصر لم يتسع
لرئيس منتخب معزول عن الحكم ومعزول في
السجن حتى عن مقابله اسرته
[موسيقى]
ومحاميه
لعدم لقاء الرئيس باي من محاميه او اسرته
منذ اربع سنوات هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يشتكي فيها الرئيس من تعرض حياته
للخطر داخل
[موسيقى]
محبسه لماذا طالب محمد الغيطي باعدام بعض
وزراء الحكومه المص
بالقباقيب وزير الصناعه حاطط لي نفسه
بالميو واللبس البحر على على صفحته وزير
الماليه حاطط ايه حاطط مشهد رومانسي لمين
لرشدي اباظا وسعاد حسني صح كده ده وزير
الماليه اللي هو اساسا مطين عيشتنا خلى
عيشتنا هباب في هباب هنا مافيش اقسم بالله
العظيم البلد دي فيها مسؤولين عايزين
عقوبه شجره الدر يضربوا بالقباقيب لما
يموتوا لرمضان مصر نكهه خاصه وفي
التحضيرات لاستقبال الشهر الكريم فوانيس
اضواء ماكولات حلويات وعصائر واحمد موسى
احمد موسى يكرر من العام الماضي شريط
تحدير المواطنين من قائمه من الماكولات
والمشروبات فيتحول الى شايف وشيخ وطبيب
وحلواني موسى بين رمضانين شهر رمضان ياتي
الينا تبدا الناس تنزل تشتري
والياميش
واحنا والاسعار شويه بلح مع شويه لبن تنقع
في اللبن كده اهو كوبايه زي كده واحنا كنا
متربيين على ياميش يعني شويه ليمون نعصر
مع شويه سكر
قدب زي الفل مش لازم قر الدين وما بحبوش
قر الدين انا شهر
العباده هو شهر العباده ومش شهر الاكل
بالمناسبه يعني عين الجمل ب 180 جنيه
هيعمل لك ايه يعني هيعالج من القلب وكل
واحد يجيب على قده شويه لو حابب في حاجات
ناس مش هتقرب لها ممكن اول يوم ومش مهم 29
يوم الباقيين مش مهم القطايف ولكن مهم اول
يوم قطايف لازم القطائف مالهاش حل
يعني زعيم ميليشيا العصائب في الحشد
الشعبيه العراقي قيص الخزعلي يتحدث
بشفافيه
سنستلم ببدر مكتمل ان شاء الله بغور صاحب
الزمان تكون الفرق القتاليه قد
اكتملت حلس ثوري في ايران حزب
الله في لبنان انصار
الله والحشد المقدس اخوه زينب واخوانهم
واذا كانوا يقولون هلال شيعي لا ان شاء
الله بدر شيعي الخزعلي يستقبل وزيري
الدفاع والداخليه في الحكومه العراقيه في
ان واحد ويضع واحدا على يمينه والاخر على
الشمال وقد تميز الوزيران اثناء وقوفهما
بحسن السيره والخلق نرحب اشد الترحيب
بزياره السيد وزير الدفاع العراقي المحترم
السيد ارفان الحيالي وزياره السيد وزير
الداخليه المحترم السيد قاسم
الاعرجي باسلوب غامض ومثير وعلى طريقه
المنجمين وزير الداخليه العراقي الاسبق
الذي يحمل اسمين بيان جبر صولاغ وباقر جبر
الزبيدي يتوقع ان تكون المعركه القادمه
لتنظيم الدوله على اسوار مكه وفي جنوب
الاردن المعركه القادمه هل ستكون على
اسوار مكه مثل ما تنبات ان المعركه ستكون
على اسوار بغداد نعم
المعركه على اسوار مكه بالمعنى العام
لكنها
ستكون في احدى كبر المدن السعوديه
جانب
وستكون في احدى المدن الكبرى في الاردن
ماذا كان يعمل صولاغ الزبيدي قبل اهتمامه
بالتوقعات المستقبليه وانا مهندس مدني
تدري انا رئيس تحرير مثل ما ان افهم الامن
لخبرتي السابقه اتدرب على اللحامي اناي
كنت ادرس قران يعني انا كنت ادرس كما
قلتلك وضع الامن يعني في التمثيل انا كنت
مع الاخ قاسم الملاك قبلها كنا نمثل في
بيوت يعني وزير ا رجل اعمال تاجر وصناعي
شويه اشتغلت مقاولات سنه او سنه ونص بقي
ان نعرف من اين حصل متعدد المهن والمواهب
علومه الامنيه جابك على الامن عناوينك
كلها ما تقرا امن مهندس رجل
اعمال اشتغلت بالاعلام نعم اشتغلت
بالاعلام وسياسي وسياسي لكن الامن كان في
الظل من طفولتي كنت اتابع ارسي لوبين كنت
اتابع كريستو والى اخره من
[موسيقى]
المسلسلات بامكانك في انتخابات العراق ان
تبصم بالاصابع العشرين يعني بالايدي
والارجل فتسجل 20 صوتا اخر صيحات النائب
فائق الشيخ علي كل واحد اطو عشر بطاق
انتخب بعشرته لانه كلهن الخنصر والبنصر
والوسطى والسبابه والابهام خمسه ماي خمسه
عشره يعني يجوز همات البعض ما ادري نزع
وخلى اصابع قدميه قد يكون هم يطلع 20 هدول
منتخب بدل عشره منتخب 20 اخيرا طلب مواطن
عراقي يد ابنه مدير الرعايه الاجتماعيه
زوجه صالحه لابنه المعوق الذي يعاني من
متلازمه داون ذلك ان الرعايه الاجتماعيه
تشترط عليه الزواج لتمنحه راتب اعاله عمره
16 وشهرين 16 وشهرين يقول لي الا تروح
الزوجه يا الله اكو قانون مدير شعبه
الرعايه مال الكاظميه يقول الزوجه يا
قانون هذا و هذا موسى بن جعفر هسه اتمم وه
طلع المعامله مالته من من 2015 شهر اثلاثه
هسه طلع يقول تزوجه يلا اكو قانون خلي نط
المدير المدير مال الرعايه خلي نعطيه
البنيه الها خل ازوجه ازوجه هسه خل ينط
بنته ينط بنته اكل العراق منز الفاو ظلت
على هذا هذا
[موسيقى]
ش ختاما سال سلطان احد النبهاء الظرفاء
ماذا نفعل بسارق اودعته الشرطه في سجوننا
فاجاب النبيه اذا سرق عن طمع يا مولاي
فتقطع يده اما اذا سرق عن حاجه فتقطع يد
الحاكم الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء سامحنا يا يا الله وارحمنا يا
رب وامنح رزقك
للاف وابعد عنها كل
[موسيقى]
الاوا
ه